[Music]
how's it hanging reject nation it's your
boy the hump man flow coming and Seana
on a rainy afternoon here to check out a
brand-new movie trailer new annapurna
joint from what I understand a movie
that just got picked up out of spots
called sorry to bother you this is the
directorial debut from boots Riley who's
rapper producer and now film director
and I'm excited to check this out the
stars actually one of my favorite kind
of up-and-coming I guess you could call
him up-and-coming he's he's pretty
established now I guess but the Keith
Stanfield as the star of this movie and
if you haven't seen Atlanta all boy
Darius is just a magical character also
just a quick shout out and a thank you -
Mariah Garcia for coming over last week
to collab with us she and Greg actually
shot a reaction to this trailer and the
footage came out kind of messed up
unfortunately so we weren't able to use
it but you know go check her channel out
give her some love yeah I'm excited to
check this out don't know much about it
before we hop in just want to give a
quick shout out to everybody who's
joining us over on patreon really
appreciate you guys we've got a really
great community growing over there and
we're putting up a lot of exclusive
content including full-length music
video reactions TV show reactions the
occasional movie watch along behind the
scenes stuff whole bunch of things over
there in terms of TV Greg's been
covering attack on Titan in the flash
I've been doing Riverdale Marvel's
Runaways and I just started the second
season of Atlanta actually and then
together we cover Jessica Jones my hero
academia Black Lightning probably gonna
add some more stuff as time goes on as
things get more efficient but if you're
interested in any of that stuff come
join us over there help support the
channel and without further ado sorry to
bother you
but I'm just out here surviving able to
deliver won't even matter
oh god no
[Music]
yeah David Cross
[Music]
see that you want to say no but I
wouldn't do that before you see what I'm
offering a whole lot of people in this
movie
damn I couldn't want to watch that again
holy [ __ ] man as I love the look at this
just just off the bat man I love the
surreal tone that they're going for here
this looks like a movie that probably
has an aura and and a vibe completely
unto itself there's just something I
really love about when when slice of
life meets abject absurdity and that's
definitely the vibe I pulled off this
trailer anyhow I mean it seems like the
Keith Stanfield is struggling down on
his luck and then there's one little
saved piece of wisdom from Danny Glover
which it's cool to see Danny Glover you
know in a movie again it's been a while
since I've seen him in in anything just
this one little cue of use your white
voice blows the doors open for him and
and I gotta imagine in an odd way and a
telemarketing scenario especially it's
like people already don't want to talk
to you and if those people are you know
kind of racist that's only gonna make
things worse and so I love this this
weird concept they've come up with and I
love the look at the cast - I mean I
think Luke Heath stanfield and Tessa
Thompson are both really great I'm
excited to see them together you know as
a couple of some sort Terry Crews always
cracks me up Steven Yeun I think I
spotted in here at one point which is
cool to see his career continuing on him
taking more interesting project post the
walking dead Danny Glover like I said I
see Danny Glover in a movie and army
hammered - I mean seems like army
hammers had some bum luck at the start
of his you know major career but lately
anyway it seems like he's picking some
really cool and interesting things and
I'm excited to see what he brings to
this as well Elmo but very handsome that
piece of paper that's just a sharpie
with a little smiley that says I'm
offering you a hundred million dollars
it's so wacky and I just can't wait to
see this and as far as a directorial
debut goes for for boots Riley writing
and directing in fact this looks really
strong it looks like it has a really
strong grip on its tone and the vibe it
wants to put out there which is just
really cool to see I love one eye when a
filmmaker can make a debut like this and
from what I understand from just doing a
little background research I bet the
soundtracks gonna be pretty cool too
because they got tuned yards and the COO
to do I guess a collaboration on that or
at least to both contribute to it and
from what I understand the
who is actually the hip hop band that
boots Riley is the frontman for so
that's always cool to me personally yeah
as a person inclined towards filmmaking
and towards music I always appreciate
when a director can kind of contribute
to their own soundtrack and help mold
the movie that way it's another thing I
always appreciate about like Robert
Rodriguez movies and stuff like that and
the more I find out about this movie the
more it just seems like every aspect is
going to be interesting and is going to
be fine-tuned so I imagine that this
movie is gonna kind of be firing on all
creative cylinders and just looking at
the different scenes they present us
with here I love the look of everything
I love the different designs and color
choices and these very familiar sort of
urban and suburban areas combined with
these more strange and off-the-wall set
pieces and stuff and just those like
heightened reality moments like when he
drops through the floor or when they're
in bed and it's clear like the sheets
are popping up and the pillows are
changing and stuff like that kind of
breaking the fourth wall calling
attention to the fact that you know this
is a fantasy I love when people can pull
those off in a really snappy way it
makes me wonder to what this movie's
gonna unfold like because at least in
this trailer there are so many like
little strange details tucked away and
spliced in these really quick edits and
stuff especially the beginning that
whole like have a cola and smile [ __ ]
so I'm loving the sense of humor that
I'm catching off of this and Dave David
Cross is just the perfect choice for
your white voice your stereotypical
white voice and see see so many of these
different characters see Danny Glover
look Keith Stanfield is conversing in
David Cross white voices is pretty
hilarious and pretty on point for me
anyway you know as a white guy I think
that's pretty friggin funny and just the
color and the design and lighting
choices and stuff that I'm pulling off
of this trailer got me really excited I
just can't wait to see this man this is
this definitely just based off this
trailer alone it's kind of shot up to
the top of my anticipation list and like
I said I just love LA Keith Stanfield
and everything I've seen him in this far
have not seen Death Note
I heard L was a bit strange but I do
like this guy a lot and I'm excited to
see him lead a film especially a film
like this I can't wait so what did you
guys think hit us up in the comment box
below let us
your thoughts and as always you can
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification bell to get updated every
time a review or a video is out check us
out on the patreon link in the
description for that as well as on the
Stardust app in on viewer reviews calm
really liked working with both of those
guys really great services they're
providing and a good place for you know
movie fanatics to congregate and share
their thoughts check those out and until
next time guys a Cheers